we'll just start right off with you know
what is the state of covet 19
in southern nevada right now and if
you're able to provide
uh you know the most recent numbers on
hospital beds ventilators that sort of
thing
that'd be great as well sure kate you
know uh southern nevada hospitals just a
current status of where we're at
um about 82 of our beds are currently
occupied
with about 14.8 percent of those
patients
being coveted confirmed patients the
icu's um we're in pretty stable shape
but we're
very concerned about the current
positivity rate that may
quickly change our numbers but we're at
66 percent
occupied and about 34.5 percent
are coveted positive as we speak right
now
i see and then do you have any numbers
as well on on ventilators or that sort
of thing
sure ventilators you know we're in
really good shape
all the hospitals in southern nevada
worked really
tirelessly and with the support of the
governor in the state to be able to
acquire ventilators
we've learned a lot about ventilator use
we realize that that is the last resort
versus early intervention of ventilators
but
we have 915 ventilators in southern
nevada
and 31 of those are currently in use
with about 28.4 on covet positive
patients
right now i see and you know kind of
going into some of the remarks that
governor syslak said and he did note the
nevada hospital association noting
monday
marked the highest recorded number of
hospitalizations since mid-august
then in that joint statement this
morning you along with some others said
there is more available hospital
capacity now than this time last year
and those two statements seem to
contradict each other a little bit so
can you provide any clarification on
that
absolutely i think you know what we're
experiencing this experiencing in the
state
is definitely one of our highest covet
positivity rates
but we're watching it very closely and
support the governor on the concern that
that ultimately does translate to more
hospitalizations
more deaths unfortunately and so we're
just trying to get ahead of this and
asking everyone to really
do their part as the governor mentioned
we can't do it alone
we have to do this together and uh but
right now we're in a stable
bed capacity we have capacity
but we just don't want to get into a
surge capacity or overwhelming
our hospitals and the current positivity
rate
on the way it's trending is approaching
our highest numbers and will surpass our
highest positivity rate
we just want to make sure that that
doesn't translate and
overflow our hospitals so we want to get
ahead of it early
but we've developed great search plans
collectively
of all the hospitals in southern nevada
we've not had to execute those and
nor do we want to and we're just asking
for everybody's help so
we support the governor people try to
stay home limit your movements
make sure you're doing all the things
that we should be doing but right now
um our positivity rate is concerning and
we're just trying to get ahead of that
especially for our economy here in
southern nevada we want to make sure we
kept
keep open we've done such great work
over the last three to four months
but unfortunately that's being unwound
and we're going backwards
where we want to keep pushing forwards i
see and we're definitely going to
touch on that in just a moment with with
the economy but
back on the statement i guess it just
seemed like um
you know the the statement was painting
a bit of a different picture
than the governor uh stated last
night but you both you know everybody is
in agreement that
this is serious and we need to get this
under control
it is serious and right now we're we're
in a good
position we've worked hard to be able to
get to that position
but as the governor mentioned our
hospitalizations are trending
definitely in the wrong direction we're
not at our peaks that where we saw
uh in april and then july at the july
fourth weekend
so we're just trying to avoid that and
be get really ahead of this
so but we're in good shape but that can
quickly change
kate and we want to make sure that that
doesn't uh put us in a reason to be able
to
have to roll back any type of the
progress that we've made
i see and um now kind of going into the
hospital capacity
again so if there's more hospital
capacity now than
pre-pandemic do you think that people
are
avoiding going to hospitals due to covet
or what's your response to those
individuals
yeah i think we're seeing a combination
of things i think there still is a
hesitancy to
seek out care in certain uh pockets of
our community whether
um you're vulnerable or you're concerned
about hospital safety but i assure you
we have taken
and far exceeded all the precautions and
cdc guidelines for
patient care in all of our hospitals so
i think there is some
residency to seek out care we want to
make sure that
if you're sick or you're not feeling
well you have an emergency please seek
out care
we don't want to see anybody delay and
do more harm
but overall i think the mask and
the social distancing is definitely
having a big impact on the early signs
of flu
kate i typically were we're in the
middle or
at the beginning of the flu um but we've
seen a very mild flu season
so far i think there's been one
hospitalization in the entire state
related to the flu so
i think we're ahead of that as well so
we've got capacity so
i think it's a combination of all those
things people are seeking out clear in
the right setting
using telehealth talking to their
doctors over the phone
and they're staying home being healthy
but also the early signs of the flu
um it seems to be we're ahead of that so
far as well
so combination of those are putting us
in a pretty good position
even though we've got uh cova patients
that we're treating currently in all of
our hospitals
and let's see here just want to make
sure him so
you know when it when it comes to this
recent surge in cases
you know we expected a surge in the fall
but
for people asking you know where are
these cases coming from is it
you know fatigue not wearing masks is it
you know holidays like you mentioned
where
where is this surge coming from well as
the governor mentioned we've got
many the vast majority are doing all the
right things
and uh hearing all the signs and the
warnings that we're
bringing out but as i move throughout
the community and
check on our our hospitals and and have
dialogues
we definitely see non-compliance and
i think we all see it we just need to
care for each other
make sure caring for our families but
also
let's care about the economy too because
you heard the governor two weeks we've
got two weeks to get this under
control it's going to be a huge task but
we need everybody to participate
so that's all we're asking and let's
just
flatten this right now let's get ahead
of it so we don't have to roll back
our economy in las vegas we just cannot
afford to do that
yeah and that leads nicely into my next
question which is you know
governor syselek said in the next two
weeks there needs to be a
significant reversal of these trends do
you think that's
attainable based on where we're at right
now
you know where we're at as far as
positivity and you heard the governor
we're
right around 14 and our public testing
sites we're seeing
unfortunately higher numbers than that
and so i i think it's a huge
task to be able to to bring that back in
but
we can't do it alone we need everybody
to to do their part and listen to the
governor's
advice and guidance it will have an
impact if we all do it
but i'm very concerned kate that that
may not be an achievable task
if we don't all work together so again
we're just trying to get ahead of it the
governor's doing all he can
and all of our officials here in
southern nevada
be able to keep nevadans safe so that's
what we're really trying to shoot for
sure and that again needs leads nicely
into my next question
which you know it's this lack he said
we're essentially walking a tightrope
between
keeping the economy open keeping the
community safe
and you know some locals think that's
kind of a double standard where
okay i have to hunker down but tourists
can go to the strip and
go to restaurants what's from a medical
standpoint you know what's your message
to the residents of las vegas who might
see that as a double standard
yeah and i can see that viewpoint we
just uh
need to make sure that we're doing all
the things that we advise but it is a it
is a fine line and
you know with the thanksgiving
approaching us and wanting to be
close to family and and especially
indoors
as the weather continues to cool uh it's
it's definitely a challenge so we
definitely need more enforcement
we need more compliance and we're able
to contact trace where those issues are
and as the governor mentioned you'll
definitely see more enforcement
more surveillance happening to be able
to make sure that we
don't roll back all the hard work we've
done collectively
here in our state so but it is
concerning that
we have folks out there that just are
totally ignoring the rules and
we all see it and please report that
when you see it
that's the only way we're going to be
able to um correct these uh
violations in a quick manner sure
and you know when it comes to compliance
our team was kind of talking about it
this morning you know when we go to the
grocery store
at least i'm seeing a lot of people
wearing masks when we're
i'm out and about you know running
errands what have you is there a certain
area that you're seeing non-compliance
i think we're seeing really across the
board you know
we're definitely seeing it in close
settings
where we see the contract tracing back
to
individuals just not doing they don't
have the sanitizers
they're not washing their hands or
definitely have the mask as the governor
mentioned
below the nose under the chin and that's
just
not effective and so we're seeing
pockets throughout the community
i know code enforcement and uh our
public officials are cracking down on
that and as the governor mentioned
you'll see them out and about and uh
fines will be coming
for sure and uh right before i wrap
this up because i i know you have things
to do
i just want to make sure i have um
your statement correct kind of going
back to the beginning
of our conversation you know i guess to
in layman's terms for people watching at
home
you know how can there be um
the most available hospital capacity
than this time last year
you know as we're seeing a surge in
cases and
hospitalizations would you mind just
explaining that one more time
sure kate yeah right now we're in a
good position we've worked hard to be
able to
flex up our surge beds and have capacity
should we have a second search and what
the governor is saying
is we want to continue to make sure that
we're in a good position to be able to
handle
the patients that we're caring for and
not have to roll back visiting hours
closing down elective surgeries uh being
able to
keep businesses open be able to move
throughout the community
and that's really the concern northern
nevada definitely is experiencing
a faster rate of hospitalizations
than southern nevada but we know that
this virus
does not discriminate between north and
south so
we just are lessons learned that we've
learned from the first surge
that a high positivity rate will
definitely
overflow and translate into higher
hospitalizations
and but we are ready we've not had to
execute any of our search plans
at this point but we just want to make
sure that
the community knows that all the
hospitals are have capacity
but we definitely don't want to get to
that 100 percent
105 capacity because
other economic things happen so we're
just trying to make sure that people do
their part
sure so we're we're not necessarily in
that
second surge but we're we're we're
getting close
yeah we're we're not at that second
surge at this point kate but we're
definitely heading in that direction
and we're just trying to make sure that
we all work together to not to get to
that point
we know that the flu is out there it
will uh
continue to be out there especially as
we get the weather gets colder and the
winds
and those respiratory illnesses and
flu-like symptoms happen
and so when you layer in flu and covet
that's a perfect storm for
overflowing and hospitals being
overwhelmed with a surge of patients
that we just can't handle
and but we're definitely heading in that
direction based off our positivity rate
we're just wanting to make sure that we
flatten that or
even move it in a downwards trend to
avoid that
hospital capacity issues got it thank
you so much for
for clarifying that again i just want to
make sure i'm you know representing what
you're saying accurately
um and then just last question for you
is there anything else that
you want to add um about what we talked
about anything i didn't ask about that
you think is important to get across
you know i think you did a great job
covering it you know i think
all the hospitals have worked really
collaboratively together and we took
that time when the stay-at-home order
was
in place to make sure that we were
prepared ready
our therapeutics and our treatments have
come a long way
and we're seeing declines in the length
to stay and better outcomes than we did
initially
and i think that's also contributing to
the
hospital capacity where we're able to
treat patients more on an outpatient
basis versus in the emergency department
or
ultimately in an icu so with regeneron
coming and some other therapeutics that
have been able to isolate
and protect the healthy cells of
patients i think that's also helped our
capacity but also the decline at least
in the
trending of deaths so we're getting
we're getting better at this and
treatment
and just appreciate all the healthcare
workers the doctors the nurses the
respiratory therapists that have
done an amazing job and not taking a
break really
since the beginning we continue to work
day and night
caring for patients that have covet yeah
they've
done a tremendous job and i know we're
all so grateful for them
um thank you so much for taking the time